being a speaker at this seminar series
is I mean it means a lot to me
personally uh when I was an undergrad
back in 2006 seven I've been meaning to
learn about HCI but I didn't really have
that many resources so I had to rely on
online resources and the this seminar
series recordings have been posted
online and I've I think I've watched
pretty much everything to really you
know learn about HCI and then I came as
a master's student here um in 2008 and
took 547 pretty much for the entire two
years I was here and now I feel great
that I you know get a chance to speak as
a speaker so this is great uh today I
want to talk about interaction Centric
AI uh this is a reprise of the Europe's
uh keynote talk that I gave two weeks
ago in front of thousands of AI
researchers I tried to reframe it a
little bit so that it's uh more
customized for an HCI audience uh rather
than an AI audience but the idea is that
I want to you know think about using
human AI interaction at the center of
developing AI Technologies and of course
I don't have to preach to the choir that
human AI interaction actually matters uh
but like diving deeper based on my
experience of building these interactive
systems in different contexts like
education discussion decision making I
want to kind of dive deeper and Report
some of the detailed interactions that
we've been
observing and learning from and think
about you know what it means to design
human AI interaction in various contexts
and what are some action items moving
forward as a community
so let's first start with some
definitions and terms I would say the
you know dominant Paradigm for
developing a Technologies has been model
Centric the idea is to build a model
with high accuracy and we want to
evaluate it against unseen examples for
its generalizability and benchmarks have
been great in that they could help us
competitively compare different models
performances which could be useful in
making science scientific advances
possible
and more recently people have been
talking a lot about data eccentric AI
where the idea is using this you know
nicely performing model uh what is a
good sort of robust and efficient data
pipeline around it in terms of
collection of the data processing of it
cleaning of it so that the model
actually performs really well in
different contexts and here the focus is
acquiring a quality data and setting the
pipeline in a way that really helps the
machine perform its best
and you know these two uh paradigms are
great uh but then what is slightly
missing is the user who's uh using these
AI Technologies and those who are
affected uh by what the AI systems give
you so interaction Centric AI is sort of
uh my term in some contrast to model
Centric and data Centric AI where the
goal would be basically what HCI
researchers uh do in this context like
improving the user experience by
building uh usable and useful
applications and the unit that we often
grapple with uh is a human AI
interaction
and you might be wondering so is this
some sort of like marketing term like
how is it different from Human centered
human-centric AI we've been talking all
about uh it's largely similar so I'm not
trying to say I invented this new term
or anything uh but I want to you know
focus our attention to the interaction
that is happening between humans and Ai
and the complex relationships and the
Dynamics that are happening between the
two rather than focusing on just uh the
humans or machine alone so you can say
that that's sort of the focus of where
my sort of discussion will be today
so let's say you're this uh you know AI
researcher uh and your team has built
this amazing model uh so this is
actually you know something that I
copied and pasted from uh one of the
diffusion models papers I don't know
what they actually mean as some of them
I understand uh but basically this is
what you have uh as an AI uh researcher
but what would a person using this kind
of AI want to do with it
here's an example uh so this is a twitch
streamer in South Korea who was trying
to use this diffusion based uh text to
image generation model to create this
image of an animated character eating
ramyan with chopsticks with noodles
around the character so this is the the
roughly sketched out goal that the user
currently has and he ended up spending
two hours uh fiddling with text-based
prompt to get at the final image that he
wants
um and this is you know someone similar
to what Manish shared a couple weeks ago
at the Hai conference in terms of what
he had to do uh with the uh prompt based
interface and here the entire two-hour
Journey was live streamed
um so I want to kind of share a quick
summary of what happened in that stream
and of course we need something in the
middle to bridge between the technology
and the human user and that's what we
have the prompt based interface and
interaction that's happening between the
two
so the streamer started by something
simple and obvious The Prompt says
eating Ramen and this is what he got
it's okay it's kind of there the but the
bowl is perhaps too large the Chopsticks
are already placed and he uh heard from
somewhere that you know adding a full
sentence might make things better so he
goes she is eating Ramen uh
she is eating ramyan for sure but you
know if you can see that something's not
quite right
um so he keeps going on by adding more
descriptions and the The Prompt is
definitely getting longer
um and it seems that the AI is not quite
getting how Chopsticks should be used
and like how many uh should be used so
he keeps adding these descriptions to
really explain what it means to use
chopsticks
um and so and and like to be to be fair
uh you know there's hair there's
Chopsticks there's noodles so it's uh in
like computer Graphics like dealing with
human hair I heard is a really tough
Challenge and maybe for AI it's also
kind of struggling to deal with all
these uh similar looking objects and it
doesn't really seem to get what uh how
to differentiate between Chopsticks and
noodles
another interesting aspect was that
since it was a live stream uh the
viewers were actively participating uh
in like uh recommending new prompts to
try out sharing their interpretations
and this is so somewhat of a
collaborative mental model construction
process fuel right as a group of people
they are really trying to figure out
what's going on and now the prompt is
like five five lines long
and this is the service that the
streamer was using was supporting uh
variations where you could pick an image
and say create some variations and he
was referring to this interaction as
variation gotcha so gacha is a Japanese
word for like a random box or blind box
and this kind of tells us that how
unpredictable this sort of interface is
right once you hit the generate button
the user doesn't really have a good
sense of knowing what to expect and this
is the actual stream as you can see like
he's praying and which also uh tells us
about the usability of this serve system
the he doesn't have a good way of
knowing what to expect so that he
actually has to pray
after two hours of hard work this is a
final image that he landed in and it
looks pretty good and he claims victory
but then look at what he had to do uh uh
at the top right there are seven lines
of prompt that he had to write and
arguably this is natural language but I
would say this is really pseudo-natural
language
um and so this is basically the
experience that he had to go through so
is this a good interface and I sort of
got inspired by manisha's discussion of
discussing the usability of these text
prompt based interfaces there are some
good elements right it's quite intuitive
you can use natural language or you you
believe natural language could be used
and the output is uh presented in a
visual manner which helps you kind of
understand whether you got the image
that you like or not so that you can
sort of debug and there are some
interactions uh that are supported like
variations and seeds and like uh words
that should not be used and things like
that
but there are many ways in which this
interface actually fails to support what
the actual user wants uh he had to rely
on trial and error and the just the fact
that he had to spend two hours to get
that image in to suggest that something
is really wrong
and of course it was not really
predictable and lack of specific
feedback on the effect of you know what
specific words in the prompt had uh
influence on the final outcome these
links were often missing which made it
really difficult
so is this really just a problem for
these you know text-based uh
prompt-based systems I would say every
AI application faces these interaction
challenges on the user side when they
first encounter these systems they often
have to struggle to kind of figure out
how to make it work often people resort
to misusing it abusing it and learning
takes a long time and it's part of it is
really a design challenge
and we've seen other examples like this
where people don't have a good sense of
what's happening in this algorithmically
generated systems and AI powered systems
like in the famous study of Facebook
news feed users more than half of the
participants were not aware of the
newsfeed curation algorithms existence
at all which is far from being true
and on the right what you see is in the
pathology Pathologists uh diagnosis
scenario uh often they would rely on
some notion of similarity so there are
these algorithms that are designed to
help people find similar images uh but
then the the realization that the
researchers had was that you know people
have different Notions of similarity so
a singular notion of similarity that was
used in building an algorithm would not
really suffice so what they ended up
doing was to support three different
types of similarity interaction and the
user was able to kind of transition
between these different terms in a fluid
manner which really gives more control
and agency on the user side
and these no put in a more simple sort
of diagram manner whether you are a
Creator or Facebook user pathologist you
seem to have some kind of a mental model
of how the system works a very sort of a
classical sort of gap between what the
user wants and the system wants and
obviously the system is not behaving in
a way that you really want and this Gap
arguably seems to be larger with these
more complex black box and you know deep
learning based systems
an AI Community has been tackling this
problem as well and you know some of the
folks have been uh
you know framing this as an alignment
problem which uh is about aligning the
model's Behavior with human intent and
for example the famous uh Chachi PT and
the instruct GPT Paradigm has been sort
of open ai's response to the alignment
problem where their idea is in addition
to the you know basic large language
model that they have they would add this
fine-tuning layer with human feedback
which often involves asking people uh
whether you know they were happy with
the results they got and the the system
kind of uses that feedback to train a
reinforcement learning agent to do the
fine tuning so that the resulting text
aligns better with what the user wants
and they were seeing some success around
it and a quote from the paper is that
making language models bigger does not
inherently make them better at following
a user's intent
in aligning language models with user
intent on a wide range of tasks by
fine-tuning with human feedback and of
course there's been a lot of discussion
about whether this is really the the
most promising way to you know involve
humans or alignment problem I think this
is some progress towards that direction
but all of these examples I would say uh
basically lead us to revisit these
classical Notions of Gulf of execution
and Gulf of evaluation purposed by Don
Norman back in the 1980s right as a user
they want to know what's going on with
the system and they want to have more
control and agency and on the evaluation
side when AI gives you some kind of
result they want to be able to
understand it interpret it and and want
to get some explanation of it
and as an HCI researcher who's building
these interactive systems I feel like in
often cases I try to bridge these gaps I
come up with new ways of Designing these
you know social interactions and human
AI interactions in a way that tries to
bridge these gaps and these are just
some of the systems that I've been
developing in different uh application
domains and I think many of them have
somewhat succeeded in bridging these
gaps but other times to be honest we
haven't done a good job of doing that so
what I want to do for the remaining uh
time for this talk is to share some of
these lessons and some of them from like
positive experiences but other times
like bitter experiences by something
that we haven't really done a good job
of
and the main message that I want to send
across is that Beyond these Point
solutions for you know this system that
works in this particular context we've
seen some success I think as a field we
really need to uh start thinking about
can we do something more systematic and
sustainable or Empower designers and
developers in thinking about uh can can
we develop these AI applications that
are more usable and useful for more
groups of people rather than uh you know
having to reinvent the wheel each time
someone has to develop these
applications and I think we're seeing
too many of these cases where people are
like uh there's this cool model let's
build something around it and it just
gets released in a few days and realizes
that people wanted in a completely
different way people abuse it a few days
later it goes down we're seeing too many
of these failure cases
uh so from the HCI point of view I think
uh HCI research can really Advance this
uh you know interaction-centric AI by
contributing this generalizable building
blocks for Designing these systems and
interface affordances
and AI research can also Advance by
embracing the idea of
interaction-centric AI by rethinking
models architecture design benchmarks
metrics and research process
the part of it has to involve sort of
broadening the perspective Beyond just
thinking about the model and the output
that it generates to think about the
users behind those and their mental
models and often there's not just a
single user but a group of user
community of user a society of users
and there's also the temporal Dimension
like before the user comes in and tries
to use the system we should be asking
the questions about like what's the task
and who are these users and why and how
and during the interaction we need to be
thinking about presentation
visualization
and the other way around as well like
interpretable results are being
presented to the user do they have a way
to provide feedback to the system
and also it's never going to be just a
single use right people would want to
come back and use the system for a
sustained amount of time in those cases
people's mental model would evolve and
what does it mean for the system and
so I think this is sort of the ecosystem
that I have in mind and with these I
want to dive into
um these specific uh examples where we
designed human AI interactions uh and I
identify four major challenges
in terms of human AI interaction
the first one is about Bridging the
accuracy Gap
so I'm on my sabbatical now I'm working
with the startup called Ringo where they
are basically Uber for language learning
they are matching uh tutors and duties
and they have this video based language
tutoring session
so what we try to do here is to build
this uh diagnostic service based on
analyzing the chat-based tutoring
session to give people like personalized
feedback and suggestions for improvement
but instead of going into the details of
the service itself I want to touch upon
the
case that we ran into when we were
trying to run this automated speech
recognition AI which is crucial in sort
of turning the video based chat into
text format which is really required for
us to run all these diagnostic
algorithms on top of
and the standard metric of success in
ASR would be word error rate you know
how correctly it can
recover the original text
and on the tutor side when we ran uh ASR
on like hundreds and thousands of
sessions the average word rate error
rate was around eight percent
uh can you take a guess as to what the
number would mean for students
obviously there's white uh margin that's
quite high so you can imagine
30.
yeah we're seeing 23. um so there's
quite a bit of a gap and this is an
example of an accuracy Gap where
different groups of users are getting
disproportionate uh results from the
same AI
and the Gap actually widens if we look
at like the best tutor and the the worst
uh student when it comes to the
performance of these models
but in terms of thinking about the
interaction that these people are trying
to have with this AI
I would argue that the students are the
ones who really need this AI to work
right based on the accuracy of this AI
they want to kind of look at where they
you know succeeded and failed and they
want to learn and reflect and with this
uh low accuracy they would really be
struggling uh to come up with good
action items and they might be
frustrated they might lose trust in the
system
but interestingly a lot of focus when it
comes to model development is that we
seem to be focusing on the six percent
like making this six percent better
instead of narrowing the gap between 60
and 36 percent
and we have to really be asking like
what is the most important question in
this context and are we really focusing
on the most important question here
and we see these other examples too uh
where you know Tyra and others have
studied the machine translation that is
being used in emergency rooms when it
comes to discharge statements that are
presented to patients and patients
families and we see a huge disparity
between different languages and in the
natural language processing Community
this support for low low resource
languages has been a you know topic for
research and there has been great
efforts
and on the right is a famous example of
gender Shades where the the gender
classification algorithm shows again an
accuracy of this parody between a darker
still darker skinned female versus
lighter scale male
and of course these diversity and
inclusion efforts and low resource
language support research in the AI
Community NLP Community have been
tackling these issues of accuracy gap of
course but then I would argue that they
could no Advance further by embracing
more interaction-centric approach in
trying to really see how in in the real
world people are interacting with these
results and what kind of actual
struggles that they have because of you
know poor or good AI accuracy and what
what as a community how can we Define
the problem that's most important
conceptually speaking I feel like a good
analogy might be the ceiling and floor
analogy the ceiling would be this
primary User Group uh you know who gets
the best part of AI uh and floor would
be sort of you know secondary User Group
who is this disproportionately getting
more negative impact of the same Ai and
there's this accuracy Gap
and often I feel like taking a
model-centric approach incentivizes uh
you know people and researchers to work
on raising the ceiling
there there could be a couple reasons
for this right first of all that's the
Sota number you get which might be what
you need to publish a paper out of it or
the benchmarks that you're working with
do not really have much data uh on the
on the floor side it's maybe more
focused on the ceiling side and that's
why the ceiling is there in the first
place right so it might be just
incentivizing uh people to continue to
push the boundaries of ceiling
and as a as a result what we see is a
matter of a widened accuracy Gap
and if we take more interaction-centric
approach I would argue that if we
identify that narrowing this Gap is a
more important problem uh we can narrow
this accuracy Gap and it's not just a
matter of accuracy if you think about it
it's about experience benefit and value
that people get out of uh interacting
with this AI
so there was a first challenge about the
accuracy Gap and how thinking about how
people interact with this AI can help us
identify what problems are worth
tackling
and second of all I want to talk about
when people actually use Ai and one of
the anti-patterns of human AI
interaction is that people just stop
using AI altogether or abandon it which
is something you might want to avoid as
a system designer
and and that's why it's important to
think about how do we incentivize people
to work with AI
and in most cases people abandon using
AI because it's not really giving them
concrete value that they expect
and we explore this in the context of
online education in this system called
axis
so the problem that we wanted to focus
here is that in online let's say you
want to learn some New Concept like
probability there are lots of problems
and answers you can find find but
finding good explanations is
surprisingly difficult and generating
high quality explanations is costly and
resource intensive and so on so we
wanted to tackle this problem by
building this online education platform
where people are presented with a
problem and they solve this problem they
submit an answer
and they see an example that's presented
by the system and they get a chance to
rate how helpful the explanation that
they saw was
and then they are getting a chance to
sort of self-explain uh their own uh
answer so this is a pedagogically
meaningful activity to be able to sort
of explain your thought process and
externalize it and lots of research
supports uh doing self-explanation
okay so fairly simple sort of front end
in terms of the learner's experience
so that's happening uh behind the scene
is that the system is collecting these
explanations and ratings from Learners
right since it's a live system uh new
Learners keep coming in and you know
providing new ratings and explanations
and we formulate this in a multi-armed
bandit manner which means that as a new
explanation comes into the system as a
byproduct of humans learning activity a
new arm gets added to the system and
what the system is doing is to determine
the sort of dynamic policy for what the
most effective explanation would be for
the next learner coming into the system
so if you're familiar with the
reinforcement learning
um Concepts uh we are navigating
exploitation and exploration trade-off
exploitation in the sense that the
system wants to present the best
explanations to the next learner coming
to the system but the system doesn't
really know what the best explanations
are until it collects some amount of
ratings from people so it has to do some
exploration where it should collect this
data
and to solve that we use technique
called Thompson sampling
so what happens is uh the system keeps
track of these policies and when a new
explanation comes in and ratings come in
these things get updated and the policy
uh
probabilistic uh policy gets updated so
that it uses this distribution to
determine what explanation to the
to show to the next learner
so when we ran a study uh these access
generated explanations were
helpful in terms of helping people learn
better so when we compared against
presenting no explanation at all and
measured uh differences between pre-test
and post-test results we were seeing
that people were gaining three percent
increase in their scores
so just getting a chance to rethink the
problem I think you know still gave them
some uh increase in their scores and
when they were seeing the instructor
generated uh explanation which is I
guess you know somewhat of an ideal case
or the standard case we're seeing nine
percent increase and with axis we're
seeing 12 increase so between these two
conditions it was not statistically
significantly different but there were
certainly cases where exes was picking
explanations from Learners there were
even more uh powerful than the
instructor generated ones
so in this system if we were to take a
more model-centric approach I think we
might have built an AI that
automatically generates high quality
quality explanations
but instead in taking an
interaction-centric approach I think the
system we created is basically this
co-learning system where the user the
learner and AI are learning at the same
time in a single system so it's sort of
a you know education
focused system of the game with a
purpose kind of setting whether organic
benefits are provided to people who are
interacting with the system and the
system is learning something useful out
of it
and this is uh basically the mechanism
that we have in that both sides are
learning and explanation and feedback
are establishing this Loop
and this is the topic of my PhD thesis
and I score this in the concept of
learner sourcing where you know Learners
as a crowd coming into the system are
basically doing this by getting their
individual benefits while they're
providing something useful for the
system to learn and do its thing better
so since then I've been expanding uh
this idea to a broad uh array of
applications so for example can we use
this kind of co-learning ideas to
summarize how-to videos in terms of like
steps and sub steps or building a
concept map out of an instructional
video that shows relationships between
different concepts
or helping Learners come up with the
solution plans uh in algorithmic problem
solving settings and other researchers
have taken on this idea in different
application contexts as well so I think
we can try to really generalize this
kind of idea of co-learning uh system
design in different contexts
right moving on to the third challenge
is about Beyond a single user and often
we think about a single user a single AI
interacting with each other in real life
it would be much more complex and
there'll be diverse configurations
so how can we consider these social
dynamics and there could be various
types of social dynamics but one
specific instance that we did in was
group based chat-based discussion in a
group
so we built this system called solution
chat where the idea is what if this AI
agent could recommend real-time
moderation messages to a group so let's
say a group is discussing you know what
to do for the company Retreat next week
and they're having a discussion the
system in real time based on the
understanding of the discussion context
and also knowing what kind of messages
would be useful for the group based on
our sort of literature survey of
discussion and discussion based
education
it presents these recommendation
messages like any more ideas or can you
can this uh person share their opinions
you have been quiet for a while
or should we try to move on to the next
uh stage or thank you for your opinion
so these kinds of moderation messages
are presented by the system in real time
just like what you get in like smart
replies in Gmail for example and as a
moderator you you can just choose to uh
you know accept any of the messages that
you like and discard the ones that you
don't like
so a quick summary of the results of
what we um saw was that in our lab study
with 55 learner users in 12 different
groups when we compared how many
moderation messages were used in
different groups when we compare the
Baseline condition without these
real-time recommendations versus
solution chatter system we're seeing a
significant increase in the number of
moderation messages that were present in
the chat stream in the solution chat
condition but interestingly you can see
that the users manually typed moderation
messages were actually decreasing in
solution check but many of them were
replaced by the accepting
um AI generated recommendations
furthermore we had a this great
opportunity to actually release this
system to over 2 000 real world users in
a corporate education setting so during
covid a lot of these corporate education
programs moved online and this company
that we worked with wanted to use this
kind of you know system to moderate
hundreds of chat rooms that were doing
uh discussion based activity
and not surprisingly just like the the
very first uh live stream prompt example
that I mentioned here again people were
collaboratively trying to understand the
capabilities and limitations of AI when
they were first presented with the
system
so they were you know using the chat to
test different messages often you know
things that they believe would be not
working and they would be sharing the
results of you know oh this is working
this is not working I think this is does
this well but not that well and it seems
as if you know as a group does this kind
of testing in the very first phase of
their usage of the system people have
this shared expectation of the system
and that seems to sort of determine
their further interactions with the
system and it was also notable how
different groups had different
expectations based on their limited
experimentation that they did in the
beginning
and there were some interesting social
dynamics that we observed as well uh
like in how people use these AI
recommendations uh to socially interact
with with each other
some people were using AI as proxy so
one of the quotes that we had was I
didn't want to directly ask the person
to stop talking so the person relied on
the AI recommended message to kind of
send it they still chose to send it but
it was their way of kind of softening uh
the potential sort of dispute with the
person
other people were using AI as a
reference so what we were seeing is that
it was a fairly simple technical
pipeline that we had so it was just a
like hand response so people were
sometimes uh not really fond of the tone
of the message style of the message that
we showed so the person said I found no
fun in the recommended messages because
all the messages look the same so in
those cases what people did was they
still adopted the idea from the
recommendation but then wrote it rewrote
it so that it's more
feels more personal and it feels more
like it's coming from them not AI
in other cases AI seems to be adding the
social burden so in this excerpt so one
of the people said I'm doubtful about
The credibility of AI and then the
moderator picks this AI recommendation
thanks for your opinion another person
says I also think negatively thanks for
your opinion thanks for sharing a good
opinion shall we go to next topic and
then the moderator realizes he might
have you know clicked accept way too
many times and it was a little unnatural
so he stopped to kind of uh clarify and
apologize for you know sorry for my
unnatural words as I'm using a
recommendations
so while we were seeing how people were
saving their time and you know cognitive
effort in moderation could have
decreased it might have actually
introduced uh other types of Burden at
the same time
again so if we were to build this kind
of system in a more moral-centric manner
I think a good alternative might have
been automated discussion moderation
where AI would actually do all the
moderation by itself
but instead we chose to take a more AI
assisted moderation for obvious reasons
users want to have more agency and
control and they wanted to keep their
style of communication so instead of you
know handing over the entire control to
AI we still sort of gave that control to
the human moderator who could kind of
use it as an additional resource
okay so there was a third challenge
and moving on to the final challenge of
supporting sustainable engagement here
the concern is that we want to think
Beyond this you know single session
usage and over time you know how people
react to these systems might change
their mental model might change and how
AI actually works might change so we
need to really think about this temporal
Dimension more carefully
and for this uh
thread we investigated in the context of
novices making changes to websites that
they're seeing so for example you might
have a case where you visited this
website that colors hurt your eyes or
you couldn't really find this button or
tap it because it's too small maybe you
want to make it larger but then people
without expertise in HTML and CSS have
difficulty doing this so we thought by
leveraging the power of large language
models and so on maybe we can support
more natural language queries so if a
person says tone down the text the
system can kind of display these style
recommendations that they can explore
and select from that are about toning
down the test
so the way the system works is if the
user clicks
and says make this larger the system
presents a set of design attributes that
are about making something larger
and the user can say
emphasize this part it's something
somewhat ambiguous right there isn't a
clear single design attribute that is
about emphasis right so it presents
these a few recommendations that are
about emphasizing something
so we built this by establishing this
NLP Pipeline and computer vision
Pipeline on the NLP side what it does is
analyzing the user's query and turning
mapping them uh with the style
attributes that seem to be connected to
what the user's intent is about
in terms of computer vision we collected
millions of web design
elements to determine a good set of
recommendations to show to the learner
so by combining those we built this
system
again so instead of going deep into the
technical details of the system I want
to focus on the interaction Dynamics so
we ran this user study with 40 people
where we presented them with either
stylet which is the name of our system
versus the Baseline the Chrome developer
tools which is sort of the standard tool
for making these style changes
so we compare these two groups and we
gave people two tasks one is a
well-defined task where the we ask
people to turn this before image into an
after image and then secondly we had
this open-ended task where we gave this
blank slate and people were able to make
any kind of change that they want
first I want to share success stories
people were more successful in
completing these design tasks when using
stylet like 80 percent of the styloid
users completed the task as opposed to
only 35 percent in Chrome developer
tools and these were complete novices in
web design like no experience at all
and people completed the task in 35 less
time so it was efficient to use dialect
another interesting observation was that
people were making the same similar
number of changes in both conditions but
in style condition people were making
more diverse changes which means that it
probably had to do with how stylet shows
this you know multiple options for
people to explore and there was a
conscious decision to not just show the
most obvious one but show somewhat
related ones as well so that people
could explore and Tinker around
different options
but then an unexpected finding was when
we looked at people's self-confidence
because we thought this kind of system
would be useful for people's learning of
the skills and confidence that they have
about the skills we asked people
self-confidence after each task what we
noted was that after the first task in
both conditions people's self-confidence
increased but then in the second task
after the second task users
self-confidence decreased for styled
while in the developer tool it kept
increasing
why would that be the case and we were
seeing many cases where Starlight users
were frustrated that the only control
that they had was natural language
now they have some grasp of how it works
they wanted to do more fine grain
control more directly and they wanted
more specific things but because they
only had natural language they sometimes
just got frustrated
whereas in the Chrome developer tools
condition people were just happy that
they accomplished something uh with
their own hands and I think that you
know kind of uh is presented as a
continued increase in self-confidence
and we know from you know HCI and like
from cs147 that you know people's expert
expertise and learnability uh really
matters and as they have more knowledge
of the you know domain and the skill
they might need to get more advanced
controls or being able to more directly
manipulate uh what they're working on so
I think this uh had some interesting
lessons in terms of thinking about the
temporal dimension in that Learners are
changing
and other researchers have been
reporting that you know considering
these uh temporal Dynamics is important
on the left what you see is uh design
researchers who have shown that there
are these different stages of
relationship that people have in
Technologies like self-tracking devices
first they would start with initiation
and experimentation followed by
intensifying and integration and then
stagnation and termination
and one of the design lessons might be
that these might be more meta level
factors that she really should be
considered in designing these systems in
that uh you know even the same kind of
intervention might need to be presented
in different manners depending on what
stage you are or what your expectation
is with the system
on the right what you're seeing is the
guidelines for human AI interaction
really influential work from a mercy at
all and they organize these guidelines
for human AI interaction in different
categories but that are organized in the
temporal sort of uh aspects like initial
encounter with AI during interaction
when things go wrong and over time so
taking into account this temporal
Dimension can really be powerful in
supporting more sustainable engagement
and the related question might be as
people are relying on relying more on
these AI tools like grammar fixes or
even generating text it's important to
think about how people's mental model
would change over time and AI also
changes over time too and
do we hit a point where people become
maybe overly Reliant in that maybe their
grammar skills or writing skills do not
you know improve anymore but then
without the tool they actually might
perform worse and what is that dynamic
or maybe over Reliance is perfectly fine
because if we believe these tools will
be around the user all the time maybe
it's just the final outcome that matters
and I think we need more studies and
Analysis of the long-term engagement of
users using these kind of Technologies
um and to kind of sum up if we were to
take a more model-centric approach here
I think we might have built a system
that makes automatic design fixes to
optimize a web page uh directly and the
system makes a fix and user can just use
it
but instead we took a more sort of
interaction-centric route where we ask
people to do sort of you know style
change by themselves as the system was
presenting these recommendations and
they still had to do the fix by
themselves but what we expected here was
that people can then customize by seeing
these attributes they can learn they can
discover new ways of doing things they
can Tinker around which can Empower them
especially in the more learning context
although the temporal Dimension has to
be more carefully taken into account
so these were the four challenges that I
wanted to uh share today and to kind of
wrap up I just wanted to pose two
questions moving forward uh from the uh
interaction-centric perspective as HCI
researchers
so first is how might we design these
building blocks and interface
affordances for new and upcoming AI
models
okay um so I think part of it is that
instead of you know building these Point
Solutions I think we need to think about
are there any sort of generalizable like
Frameworks libraries Widgets or
interface affordances that we could come
up with uh as as a community that is
really good at these kinds of things
and the second question is does AI
really require us to have these new
things I mean can we just use existing
Design Elements and you know Frameworks
to build AI applications
and I tend to think that uh we might
need something new uh for these new and
upcoming AI models especially because
they have these very different
characteristics than the conventional
systems that we have been building
they're more probabilistic harder to
predict more Black Box in nature yet
seemingly more impactful and Powerful in
terms of what they do hallucinating
right all these properties packed
together I think we might really need to
think about what are the types of
interactional affordances that are
really built for supporting the
usability of these AI powered
applications
so in this I think as a community we are
making all these great advances like
making different types of contributions
and you know I tend to focus on more
sort of interactive systems and
techniques uh well whereas other people
focus on like introducing new design
processes and understandings and I think
all this work is needed and you know
some of the interesting examples of you
know adding sort of an interaction layer
um to these uh new types of models is in
this example tail brush where the user
can kind of draw the level of Fortune
that they want in the character to have
when they use uh generative models to
generate a story
or this AI chains work which uh presents
these Primitives and workflows for uh
putting together uh this workflow that
can accomplish more complex tasks uh
with uh these llm prompts that a single
prompt cannot really perform
and in my research group with my PhD
student Tessa Kim we have been
investigating this idea of what will be
more generalizable design framework and
thinking about like input model and
output we have been thinking about the
concepts of cells generators and lenses
and try to sort of introduce this
standardized libraries and widgets that
people can easily adopt in their AI
applications so for example using this
this kind of framework people can build
a copywriting app email app or story
writing app using pretty much the same
kind of framework which can save
people's time while supporting the types
of interactions like iterations and
comparison and experimenting different
outputs
and the second question
um and the final question that I want to
ask today is how might we as an HDI
Community collaborate better with the AI
committee on these various things and it
was also the discussion that I was
having a lot with today's meetings and
also with various AI researchers
especially at nerves
and in terms of community collaboration
of course one of the important things is
metrics and there was also a great
discussion at the HEI conference a
couple weeks ago hosted here at Stanford
and in the AI Community it cares a lot
about model performance and
generalization errors where in HCI we
tend to focus on The Human Experience so
how do we really bridge the gap between
the metrics and what it means to do AI
research with more Human Side metrics
Incorporated what's the incentive for
people to do that and how do we
encourage poor AI people to kind of use
these metrics too
in terms of human input design a lot of
the the comments that I was getting in
terms of interaction Centric AI from AI
researchers is that these ideas are
great but then I don't really know how
to actually take action about it and
part of it is you know in their model
building kind of work you know how can
can I incorporate human feedback and how
do I use it in a meaningful way to
really change the way the model actually
works rather than just you know getting
a more high-level design guidelines
so the one great direction for this
might be think about more like you know
making human feedback more
computationally feasible so that this
compatibility uh is actually satisfied
and lastly we need to think about the
change in design process as well and in
a lot of uh this is Stanford D school's
uh user-centered design cycle and I
think in a lot of the AI research what
we're seeing is this prototype test kind
of culture you try something new test it
iteratively improve it but then
one of the frustrations is that
interaction often comes too late right
there's this new cool model and can you
build an UI on top of it is sort of the
kind of discourse we get a lot and I
think interaction should not just be
like an icing on the cake but really
something that can guide the entire
design process or help people determine
is this the right problem to tackle in
the first place or what what kind of
interaction should we try to support
with AI and based on that think of what
AI should do and should not do and how
much AI should be used in a particular
context
so that's uh that's all I wanted to
share and here's a summary of what I
mentioned today and I'd be uh happy to
take any questions thank you
all right so I'll check my
recommendations of facilitating messages
if there are any more ideas
no nobody's recommendations
what do you think
really sounded like an AI
I'll just click them all
I I want to pull the oh I should make
the mic on I wanna
I wanna pull the thread a little bit on
this notion of
how to connect human feedback with the
objective functions that you touched on
near the end because that's been
rattling around in my head the in much
of the talk that you're giving that you
know if I think about what should AI
researchers be doing differently
then you're sort of asking well what's
the proper model of the person in their
in their system right and traditionally
the problem's been that human
interaction is really expensive right
just to collect annotated data or once
you have it to be able to kind of tune
the model right that it it you don't get
that much of it and so they often fall
back on self-supervision or as you as
you've been talking about in the value
alignment they sort of train an RL model
to mimic a human and then you know let
that go loose and it seems like until
you know I think they're kind of I want
you to take a position on one of the two
positions one either is to say look we
need to find
strategies like that where we can create
you know proxy humans and that's how we
hook into their uh into the objective
functions the loss function Etc the
other alternative would be to say no
that we're going to find some other way
to actually make human feedback
you know
at a scale and in a form that they can
directly use in the models I'm just
curious like if if you want to take a
bet where's your bet on that where
should we be heading
yeah that's an excellent question I
would say uh
I mean you asked me to take a position
but I would say both will be prevalent
and I I like the letter much more and I
think that's more promising and
sustainable and for example the reason
I'm really interested in this uh like
co-learning uh feedback loop between the
human and the Machine is that you know
even if this super Advanced AI comes
along and let's say it presents this
like super accurate explanations people
with self-explanation activity is still
meaningful right because that that's how
they could learn and so I feel like you
know we we can't really try to find
these compatible uh
mechanisms in which the human can get
the benefit and get the incentive for
doing what they are really good at and
what is helpful for them not necessarily
trying to help the system or you know
getting paid to system paid to support
the system per se
um and at the same time the system can
use it for something meaningful and on
the system side I think in the system
like access that I presented uh
I was really happy when we landed at
this technical solution where people's
rating uh data could be almost directly
piped into the feedback for the RL agent
to kind of uh use as meaningful feedback
so I think that's just one example where
this kind of worked out for this kind of
context and I think we need to really
investigate more and think about are
there many any like generalizable
mechanisms that this kind of approach
could work in different contexts this is
assumes that you have a large set of
users you can draw them right there are
Learners that are coming through your
system if I'm early on in the pipeline
and I just kind of have v0 I don't have
the users yet are there other strategies
you would recommend yeah yeah excellent
uh so in in that same access system for
instance what we did was to uh insert
the uh instructor generated explanations
as sort of the initial seed and I was
also imagining maybe using loms for
instance we can plug in AI generated
once to kind of avoid the cold start
problem and it'll be interesting to see
how you know in the same system like AI
generated ones uh instructor generated
ones and the learner generated ones can
kind of compete against each other until
the system ultimately just focuses on
what is best for returners yeah this is
kind of a two-part question
um going back to the like third
challenge or like project you talked
about
um where there was that note about AI is
proxy like people kind of using that as
like an excuse to make points where
maybe they wanted to do something but
didn't want it to come off as them
um so the the first part of the question
is like in that case did people want to
um later it says people wanted the
message to kind of sound like them but
in the The Case of the AI as proxy did
they want that to sound like them or
were they wanting it to sound more
artificial and then second part of the
question is do you think there are more
situations than just this where maybe we
don't want the AI to feel super
personable and maybe want the
interaction to feel slightly more kind
of mechanical or unnatural yeah that's
an excellent question and I would say
these were somewhat different use cases
uh and both I think are valuable and
smite
um and
and that again I think in a more
model-centric approach we also kind of
focus on trying to create these messages
that are more like humans and that could
be effective in certain cases but as you
said that might not really be what the
users want because you know in a proxy
kind of setting you might not actually
want it to sound too personalized right
because you know maybe the more canned
message might actually work better in
that context
um and and vice versa so I think uh yeah
like just being able to like identify
all these different needs that people
have and expectations that people have
and being able to somewhat fluidly
support those I think was really an
interesting kind of uh observation that
we had and I think moving forward uh you
know one of the lessons was that you
know this like more personalizable uh
message generation could be an
interesting technology that could be
potentially integrated but that's not
going to solve everything because there
are these other types of needs that will
not be supported even with the perfect
personalizable style transfer so yeah
explaining stuff I kept thinking about
how what you described and sort of the
challenges that we see with this new
deep deep networks uh and models and how
we interact with them are similar to how
people used to interact with search
engines right at the beginning people
were not as good as sort of figuring out
how to query the search engine right and
over time both the we became better at
creating the search engines and then the
search engines became better at sort of
understanding how to interpret user
queries do you see any similarities
there do you is there something that's
very unique to the challenges we face
with this new models or is it just that
we haven't had enough time to sort of
adapt to each other in a way
um yeah excellent yeah and I think it's
a recurring theme you know as this new
technologies come in initially people
would kind of struggle and they would
need to learn how it actually works
through trial and error and lots of you
know like failed attempts and that's
what we're seeing with these like Chachi
PT for instance a lot of people are
trying things out reporting success and
failure cases
um so I do think there are certain
similarities when it comes to more what
what's more unique about what we're
seeing right now is that uh due to the
nature of like how black box complex
unpredictable these models are I think
it just confuses people much more and
there's a question of you know is this
really like a human learning problem to
begin with right so if people take do it
more and you know if they had more time
will will people be actually able to
really get to a point where they could
really easily create something that they
like probably not right so that's why I
think we need uh both on the model side
to kind of think about what are more
interactable and learnable ways of you
know architecting these kind of models
in the first place and also from the HCI
point of view what are what are these uh
interaction mechanisms that could be uh
added to these models in a way that it
is actually more understandable and
usable in the user side yeah thanks so
much yeah I think we're about a time but
duo will be here for a couple minutes
so let's thank you for speaking thank
you